おっ
私が小さかった頃の話です
小さかったので記憶にないので母親に聞いた話なんですが
非常ベルいい
jase 私のそれぞれだペル付で安心してください
すいませんに驚かせてしまってこれ私がすごい小さかった頃母親に聞いたので私は全く
身に覚えがないんですがなんか
新幹線の非常ベルを鳴らしたことがあるそうです
なんか新刊生が昔まだ個室だった当初に何か
母親がうろちょろしてる私を見てあぁをしそうだなぁ気をつけなきゃなーって思って
たら
目を離した一緒にもうすでにをしてたそうですす抵抗今のように鳴り響き
車掌さんが血相変えて飛んできてはぁはぁなんでもありませんすいませんと
なんかこの間本当に言われたので相当を根に持ってたみたいです
じゃあ今はどうかって言いますと今はですね
あのファミレスの呼び出しベルやるじゃないですか
あれがすごいオスの好きで友達といつも喧嘩になるんです
なんかそのボトンをしたり友達とケンカになることもあるんですけど基本は私がエコ
cepsa いって聞いて
メニューの決まっていない友達を急かしたり決まってないうちに
ティン34ちゃっていつも怒られています
ここまで聞くとなんか小さいことと小さい頃とやること変わってねーなーとか本当
変わってないというか子供みたいだなーって思える方がいると思います
私も実際そうだと思っています
私は身長がはどれだけ高くなっても体重はどれだけ多くなっても変わらないものって
いうのがあると思うんです
それは何か
心だと思うんです
皆さんは子供心は持っていますか
子供心私はまあボタンがあったら押したくなるし
積み上がっているものがあったら倒したくなるし
張り替えたての生死があったら破りたくなるそういうのはなんか子供心って言うんじゃ
ないかなぁと思っています皆さんはなんか子供の頃やりたかったこととかありませんか
またそれを今でもやりたいなって思うことありませんか
プレイヤーきっとあなたの中にある子供心が囁きかけているんだと思います
でそうやって小さい頃の事を思い出してみるとまぁ今みたいに結構やらかした事とか
でも褒められて嬉しかったこととかいっぱいあると思います私はそうやって自分の子供
の頃を振り返ったときにある
口癖があったなって思いました
あなたにはありませんでしたか
口癖とはなんかどうして a とか何いいとかなんでええとか
事あるごとに走ってませんでしたが
落とし戸子なんて何でみたいな感じ
最終的にはすっごいていいかい声で何でですよね
それぐらいうるさくうるさく私は言っていました
まあそのそういう疑問ですよね
妹
小さい頃ってあまりもよく知らなかったり見るものがすべて新鮮だからなんか豚のもの
に対しても疑問を持つと思うんです
例えば全中を見てあれなにか
あとはなんか映画とかドラマ見ててこの後どうなるのとか犯人誰っていうそういうのを
聞いちゃうみたいな質問の質問とか
あとはひょっとして中にはどうして私は生まれてきたのを見たいなともあったんじゃ
ないでしょうか
そういう答えのないといいというのをたまに子供は走ってきたりします
私自身も走っていました
皆さんこういう問いに答えることができますか
こういう答えのない問いなんか簡単でありそうでも実は簡単じゃない
という問いについて子どもたちと間一緒に考える
そういう活動に私は今参加しています
それは何かっていうと
見てきましたねこちらですこちら地 b 鉄という活動に参加しています
私は月に一同一番小さい子は3歳ぐらいの子からそういう子たち子どもたちが集まって
みんなでえーどうする答えのない問いテーマについて考える
そういう活動をしています
はどんなテーマかっていうと普通って何とか
友達って何とかそう言うと良いですどうでしょう答えられますか
なんか普通に日常生活で使っている言葉だったりみんなが共通概念として思っていそう
な言葉でもそれって何で聞かれるとなんか上手に言葉に出来ないそもそも方になんて
あるのかなぁってそんな風に思うと思います
ムチ美鉄の轍
てと同月とか言われるんですけど子たちがいます
チビ鉄の鉄はですねこちら哲学の轍です
私はそういう答えのない問いについて考えるその行為そのものを哲学ということを呼ん
でいます
哲学哲学なんか子供が哲学って言うとなんかすごい不釣り合いな感じがしません
私も最初そうでした
でも哲学っていうのは考える行為そのもので例えばみなさんももしかした持ってるかも
しれない
なんかいダイナーこう哲学者の言葉をなぞったり学んだりする
そういうお堅いものではなくもっと楽しいものだと思うんです
これ実際のチビ別の場面ですもう右側にいるのが私
左側にいるのは6歳の女の子なんですけどこれ本当にまさしくて通学してる場面なん
ですね
女の子の表情どうでしょう
私は哲学っていうのはなんか鬼ごっことかかくれんぼとかそういうのに近い感覚だなぁ
と思っています
例えばいいですねかくれんぼお答えを探している時ってかくれた友達を探している間
かかりすっごい近いんですよ
どこに隠れているのかなあってあちこち探しても見つからなくて
ために自分の予想もしないところに書かれてたりなんか見つかりそうにないところに
隠れてたいっ
そのい答えをやっと見つけたとしてもそのことは言葉答えを言葉にしようとした瞬間
また走り出してどっか行ってしまうんですよそれを追いかけて追いかけてまってまって
設定っていうときは何かをすごく鬼ごっこみたいだ
私は哲学って考える遊びだと思うんです
鬼ごっこやかくれんぼと同じです
楽しいものです
これは実際耳鼻てつの場面でその哲学をしていた時
今この時はしあわせって何だろうそういう問いについて考えました
子どもたちがそういう遊びの中で考えて出てきた言葉ってすごい良いものがあるんです
しあわせって何だろう
これを3歳とか4歳の子がやんです同2
皆さんでご覧ください
これも全部そのチビ鉄のば遊びの場の中で生まれてきた子どもたちの言葉です
子どもたちの考え方とか見方って先入観とかが本当にないので大人の人たちジャコウ
思い至らないような考えがポって出てくるんですねやっぱり子どもたちが一生懸命剣だ
した言葉っていうのはこう夜空に光る星みたいにすごいキラキラしていう感じます
今回てレッグ諸作のテーマは何でしょう open the box そうですね
人は誰でも自分の中に箱を持っていると私は思っています
それはもちろん子供も例外でもなく
して子供の箱にあじゃあ何が入ってるのかなーって考えたときにすごいいっぱい疑問が
入っているんじゃないかなと思います
いっぱいいっぱいアレなんだろうこれなんだろうて疑問があってその箱から溢れたもの
が必要ついてなんてやなになって来てく
まさに子供達ってすごい open the box な状態だと思うんです
じゃあこれが
閉じてしまうでどういう状態なんでしょう
開いていた箱そこから飛び出して来た疑問が誰にも受け止められない
または無言でスルーされてしまう
そういうことがあるとだんだんだんだんを度も達っていうのは疑問を発送なくなって
最終的に箱を閉じてしまうんじゃないかなって思うんです
子どもたちが考えることでとってもキラキラしてるんですそれと子ちゃんもすっごい
もったいないなぁと思うんです
私が小さかった頃なんですけど私やっぱり口癖が何ででした
すっごいなんてなんてっていううるさ y子だったと思うんですけど
ある日私の中に漠然としたある問いが浮かんできたんです
それは
死んだらどうなるんだろうという疑問でした
もちろん私は死んだこともないし周りの人たちも死んでないんだからもちろんそれが
どういうものかっていうのは分からないし周りの人が知っているとも思えないんだけど
私は気になったから普通に出してみたんですね死んだらどうなるの
そしたら周りの大人たち
その時の反応が
そんなこと言ってないで早くご飯食べなさい
とか死ぬなんて縁起悪いことを考えていないでとかでした
そこには私の欲しかった答えてものはなくただただ
言われてしまっただけだったんです
大人にそういうことを言われると
やっぱりこういうことを考えている自分が変なのかなとか
私しか考えていないのかなとか
私だけが変なのかなってそう思ってしまったんです
すごくよく覚えているのは保育園にいた時に
保育園の成立中9人氏のって何だろうって考えてしまって強くなって泣き出してしまっ
たことがありました
その時保育園の先生は必死に泣いた理由を聞いてくれたんです
でも私は
東こんなことしなってことについて考えていて強くなって泣いたなんてきっと私しか
考えていないだろう
そんなことを先生に言ったら先生はどう思うんだろう
そういう不安になって何も言えませんでした
今の私はでも逆にこう今このようにこの場に立って話せるように自由に堂々と自分の
考えを話すことができます
それは周りに受け止めてくれる人話を聞いてくれる人がいて何より小さい頃そういう事
を考えてたんだ私もっていう人にめぐり合いだからです
人は自分の考えを話しを聞いてもらえなかったりするとたちまち自信がなくなって
しまうと思います
それは子どもも例外にはなく大人にそういうことを言われてしまったら私だけが変なの
かなって
そう思ってしまうと思うんです
今の私は
どうして自分だけが考えているってあの頃思っていたんだろう
みんな子供だったんだからそういう疑問持っていたっていいはずだ
いいに私の周りにはそういうことを考えてた人がいっぱいいるのになんで受け止めて
もらえなかったんだろう
そういう疑問があります
小さい頃の私はとに周りの大人が誰も答えを持っていないことなんてわかりきってい
ました
知っていましたでもそれでも聞いてみたんです
あの時の私が欲しかった答えっていうのは正解や
が変わる答えではないんです
そうじゃなくて大人の答えが欲しかったんです
私の発した質問に対して真剣に受け止めてくれる人
そういうのが私あの頃の私には必要でした
哲学は遊びだと私は咲きましたそれは鬼ごっこやかくれんぼのようだと言いました
鬼ごっこやかくれんぼって一人でできますか
できないと思います必ず追いかけてくれる人
逃げる人が見つけてくれる人かくれる人そういう人がいて初めて成り立つんです
哲学も一緒で話を聞いてくれる人
その対話してくれる人がいないと絶対できないんです
もし今私があの頃の自分に会えるとしたら私は言いたいことがあります
一人で考えていなくていいんだよみんなでから内容
そうやって考えるのはごくごく自然なことでそしてあなたにとってとても財産になるん
だよ
増えていってあげたいんです
これ今の私の大学の仲間達です
こういう人たちがいてくれたから私は今こういうところになって来て何エギ哲学する
そういう遊ぶことが楽しいと考えることができます
こういう人たちが子どもの周りに通していないのかなっていつも思ってしまいます
あなたの周りや子供にまたあなたが小さかった頃に走ったというを受け止めてくれる人
がいましたか
誰でも1度子供でしただから子供の時の気持ちがもあなたたちには分かるはずなんです
だから子どもが走っていると良いそういうのを真剣に受け止めてみてください
そして
一緒に遊んでみてください考えることはすごく楽しくて豊かにします人を
子どもだけじゃなくあなたも一緒になって考えれば新しい箱が開くかもしれません
あなたの周りに疑問を発することもいませんか
もう一度ちゃんと確認してみてください
以上ですありがとうございました